Bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler de E = mc² et du boson de Higgs, ouais carrément !
Ce sont deux notions dont on parle souvent en vulgarisation scientifique,
et je reçois pas mal de questions à leur sujet parce qu'elles sont assez mal comprises, en fait. Dans cet épisode on va voir
ce que signifie vraiment E = mc², en quoi la question du boson de Higgs est reliée,
et au final on va essayer d'éclaircir le mystère de la véritable nature de la masse.
E = mc², et d'ailleurs je devrais plutôt dire mc carré, est probablement l'équation la plus connue de toute la physique et pourtant c'est une
des plus mal comprises, et il y a beaucoup de gens qui ne connaissent pas son interprétation exacte.
D'ailleurs sa forme actuelle, E = mc², correspond pas vraiment à ce qu'Einstein avait en tête quand il a proposé les bases de cette idée.
Une manière plus correcte de l'écrire serait m égal E sur c carré, et même encore mieux
delta m égal delta E sur c carré. Alors vous savez peut-être qu'on utilise souvent la lettre grecque delta majuscule pour désigner une variation.
Cette forme de l'équation nous dit donc que si
on fait varier l'énergie d'un corps d'une quantité delta E
alors sa masse doit automatiquement varier d'une quantité delta m égal à delta E divisé par
c au carré, où c est la vitesse de la lumière.
Ce principe que si l'énergie d'un corps varie alors automatiquement
sa masse doit aussi varier était d'ailleurs exactement ce qu'Einstein avait proposé dans le titre de son article fondateur :
est-ce que l'inertie d'un corps dépend de son contenu en énergie.
D'ailleurs à ce stade il faut bien préciser ce qu'on entend par m, la masse, parce qu'en physique classique la masse intervient à deux niveaux.
Il y à la masse dite pesante,
celle qui fait qu'un individu avec plus de masse aura un poids plus élevé et donc pèsera plus lourd sur une balance.
C'est le m qui intervient dans P égal mg, vous savez où P c'est le poids et g l'accélération de la pesanteur.
Mais il y a aussi la masse inerte,
celle qui fait que plus un objet est massif plus c'est difficile de modifier son mouvement, de le freiner ou de l'accélérer...
C'est le m qui intervient dans l'équation de Newton, somme des forces = ma, qu'on peut aussi réécrire a = F sur m
et sous cette forme elle montre bien que pour une force donnée, plus la masse est importante
plus l'accélération sera faible et donc plus la trajectoire sera difficile à altérer.
Évidemment la masse pesante et la masse inerte au final c'est la même chose, on leur donne d'ailleurs le même symbole,
mais dans le raisonnement d'Einstein il n'y avait pas de gravité, donc ce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la masse inerte.
Ce que suggère Einstein c'est donc que la masse inerte d'un corps dépend de l'énergie qu'il contient, et que donc si on modifie cette énergie
en en ajoutant ou retirant et bien la masse se trouve également modifiée selon l'équation delta m = delta E sur c².
Alors pour en arriver à cette conclusion Einstein fait un raisonnement astucieux mais qui se limite à un cas particulier.
Il imagine un corps perdant de l'énergie en émettant des photons, et il démontre que sa masse inerte doit varier selon
delta m = delta E sur c², où delta E est donc l'énergie des photons émis.
Alors faire une démonstration rigoureuse et plus générique de ce résultat est possible
mais c'est pas si simple, alors je vous l'épargne. Tout ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que cette relation est une conséquence de la
relativité restreinte dont j'ai parlé dans l'épisode précédent.
De la même manière que les notions d'espace et de temps se trouvent en quelque sorte entremêlées en relativité restreinte,
les notions de masse et d'énergie, qui en physique classique sont distinctes, se trouvent
inexorablement associées. Mais bon comme pour la masse il faut quand même préciser ce qu'on entend exactement par
énergie.Vous savez par exemple qu'un corps peut posséder de l'énergie cinétique, s'il possède une vitesse
mais on peut toujours en quelque sorte s'affranchir de cette énergie en se plaçant dans le référentiel de l'objet en question
dans lequel par définition la vitesse est nulle.
Par contre même à vitesse nulle, au repos, un système possède toujours de l'énergie résiduelle.
Il peut s'agir d'énergie cinétique interne, par exemple on peut imaginer un corps qui soit globalement au repos c'est à dire son centre de
gravité ne bouge pas, mais dont les différentes composantes ont une vitesse et donc une énergie cinétique.
Il peut aussi s'agir d'énergie potentielle, si le système ou ses composants sont en interaction sous l'effet d'une certaine force,
Enfin autre possibilité il peut s'agir d'énergie thermique. Quand on chauffe un corps on lui apporte de l'énergie qui se retrouve sous la forme d'agitation
microscopique des particules, c'est donc une forme d'énergie cinétique
microscopique. Ce que nous dit l'équation delta m = delta E sur c² c'est que si on fait varier l'énergie d'un corps par l'un
de ces moyens eh bien on fait aussi varier sa masse inerte.
Alors prenons quelques exemples pour illustrer ça. Par exemple un objet dont les composantes tournent possède une énergie cinétique
interne et donc une masse plus importante que le même objet au repos. Un ressort comprimé possède une énergie potentielle,
il sera donc plus massif que le même ressort non comprimé,
ou encore si vous prenez un litre d'eau, eh bien en le chauffant d'après cette idée vous allez augmenter sa masse.
Alors ces exemples vous paraissent peut-être un peu durs à avaler, je veux dire personne ne s'est jamais rendu compte que de l'eau une fois chauffée
devenait plus lourde, en fait pour cause parce que le changement est minime.
Alors faisons le calcul : pour chauffer un litre d'eau de 20° à 80° on doit lui apporter environ
250 000 joules, en divisant par c² ça représente une variation d'environ 3 nanogrammes, 3 milliardièmes de gramme,
donc aucune chance de s'en apercevoir. Un litre d'eau ne paraît pas plus difficile à mettre en mouvement une fois qu'il est chaud.
Mais en fait au lieu de raisonner juste sur des variations, on peut pousser le bouchon plus loin
et démontrer cette relation pour toute la masse et toute l'énergie d'un corps.
De manière générale, m = E sur c², c'est-à-dire que si je retire toute l'énergie d'un corps
en fait je lui retire toute sa masse. Et donc finalement ce qu'on appelle communément la masse
n'est rien d'autre que la mesure de la quantité totale d'énergie contenue dans un corps.
Conceptuellement cette idée est assez folle, elle nous dit qu'on avait une notion, la masse,
qu'on utilisait même si on comprenait pas forcément son origine ou sa justification
et que cette notion ce n'est finalement rien d'autre que du contenu en énergie
et c'est pour ça que c'est important d'essayer de se souvenir de cette relation sous cette forme,
m = E sur c² qui était celle qu'avait
originellement proposé Enstein et qui traduit bien qu'on explique le concept de masse à partir de celui de l'énergie.
Et voilà on a donc résolu la question de la nature et de l'origine de la masse, la masse c'est du contenu en énergie.
Alors si vous êtes un peu branché physique cette affirmation elle vous choque
probablement, ça fait quand même quelques années qu'on nous explique en long en large et en travers
que l'origine de la masse c'est le boson de Higgs,
et moi là ce que je vous dis c'est que la nature de la masse c'est juste d'être la mesure de l'énergie...
Rassurez-vous on va éclaircir ce mystère, et pour ça il va falloir qu'on se demande de quelle énergie on parle concrètement
lors on va regarder quelques exemples. Prenez un atome d'hydrogène
il est constitué d'un proton et d'un électron. Alors on connaît la masse du proton, c'est
1,673 dix puissance moins 27 kg, 10 puissance moins 27 kilos c'est ce qu'on appelle un yoctogramme,
et on connaît également la masse d'un électron, c'est
9,109 dix puissance moins 31 soit
0,0009 yg.
Du coup intuitivement on s'attendrait à ce que la masse d'un atome d'hydrogène soit la somme des deux, proton et électron
eh ben non.
Quand vous associez un proton et un électron en fait vous diminuez l'énergie potentielle du système
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils s'associent et créent une liaison. Ils s'attirent parce qu'ils préfèrent être dans un état d'énergie potentielles plus basse.
Donc la formation d'un atome d'hydrogène
libère une certaine quantité d'énergie, delta E,
et puisqu'en se formant ce système a perdu de l'énergie delta E
eh bien il a perdu de la masse : delta m = delta E sur c².
À cause de cette perte d'énergie
l'atome d'hydrogène a une masse inférieure à celle de ses deux constituants. Une manière équivalente de le dire c'est que l'énergie libérée par l'atome d'hydrogène
lors de sa formation c'est aussi celle qu'il vous faut pour le casser, qu'on appelle l'énergie d'ionisation
et quand vous séparez un atome d'hydrogène, vous lui apportez de l'énergie et donc augmentez sa masse de cette même quantité.
Alors faut être honnête la variation de masse dont on parle là en fait elle est complètement négligeable, c'est à peu près un
milliardième de la masse de l'atome donc c'est pas quelque chose qu'on arrive à détecter
expérimentalement. Mais voyons maintenant un exemple poussé beaucoup plus significatif. Prenons un atome d'hélium et on va même uniquement s'intéresser à son noyau
composé de deux protons et deux neutrons.
On l'a vu la masse d'un proton c'est
1,673 yg et pour un neutron c'est très proche,
1,675.
Alors on s'attendrait à ce que la masse du noyau d'hélium soit la somme de celle de deux protons et deux neutrons,
soit à peu près 6,696 yg, mais en réalité c'est seulement
6,646, c'est-à-dire que la masse du noyau d'hélium est inférieure à la somme de celles de ses quatre constituants.
Et on est à nouveau face au même phénomène, quand on approche les deux protons et de neutrons
on diminue l'énergie potentielle
globale du système et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que l'attraction s'exerce. Et du fait de delta m = delta E sur c² eh bien
la masse du système diminue. C'est pas une diminution énorme, c'est environ 1%, mais c'est suffisant pour qu'on puisse la mesurer.
Alors on entend parfois quand on parle de noyaux atomiques
que quand ils se forment ils convertissent de la masse en énergie selon E = mc², mais vous voyez que c'est pas vraiment ça en fait.
Quand on approche les 4 constituants l'énergie du système diminue, et comme l'énergie ne peut pas disparaître elle est en fait libérée.
Mais vous voyez bien que c'est pas la conversion de la masse en énergie, c'est de la libération d'énergie, et par voie de conséquence une baisse
de masse, puisque la masse c'est juste la mesure du contenu en énergie qui reste.
Alors on l'a dit cette diminution de masse lors de la formation d'un noyau d'hélium, par fusion donc, elle ne représente que 1%
ça paraît pas beaucoup mais en fait c'est énorme et c'est d'ailleurs cette énergie qui permet aux étoiles de briller et c'est aussi cette énergie
qu'on aimerait bien pouvoir maîtriser pour faire de la production d'électricité par fusion nucléaire.
Mais alors ça veut dire que les 99 autres % de la masse représentent une énergie encore plus grosse, c'est un truc fabuleux !
Et... elle est où cette énergie, comment je fais pour la récupérer ? Eh bien pour comprendre ça il va falloir
continuer à descendre et à s'intéresser à ce qui se cache dans les protons et les neutrons.
Comme vous le savez peut-être les protons et les neutrons ne sont pas des particules élémentaires, ils sont eux-mêmes composés de quarks.
Alors il existe six types de quark, up, down, strange, charm, top et bottom,
mais un proton est constitué seulement de 2 quarks up et 1 quark down tandis qu'un neutron c'est 1 quark up et 2 quarks down.
Et donc comme on a fait pour les atomes ou les noyaux, on peut s'amuser à regarder comment la masse d'un proton ou d'un neutron
est relié à la masse des quarks qui le constituent, donc je vous rappelle un proton
1,673 yg, un neutron 1,675. Eh bien un quark up c'est seulement environ
0,004 yg, et un quark down autour de 0,009.
Ah là voyez qu'on a un petit problème :
la masse des quarks n'est qu'une toute petite partie de la masse du proton et du neutron... bah il est où le reste ?
C'est simple, je répète, la masse c'est du contenu en énergie, et donc ce qui explique la masse des protons et des neutrons c'est
à 99 % de l'énergie d'interaction entre les quarks. Au sein d'un proton ou d'un neutron les quarks seront reliés par ce qu'on appelle l'interaction forte
c'est une des quatre forces fondamentales
ils interagissent et s'attirent en échangeant d'autres particules qu'on appelle des gluons et qu'on représente comme ça.
D'ailleurs cette représentation n'est pas innocente car on peut se représenter l'interaction entre les quarks un peu comme des petits ressorts
et ici il y a une grosse différence entre la manière dont les quark interagissent et par exemple la façon dont un proton et un électron s'attirent
dans un atome d'hydrogène.
Un proton et un électron s'attirent quand ils sont proches
mais si on les éloigne les uns des autres eh bien la force d'interaction tend vers zéro.
Avec des quarks c'est l'inverse
plus on les éloigne plus la force qui les attire devient importante, et l'attraction ne devient faible que quand on les rapproche fortement.
Et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que la représentation par un ressort n'est pas si mauvaise, avec un ressort plus vous tirez dessus plus la force
devient importante.
Et comme l'existence de cette attraction entre les quarks provoque leur mouvement
eh bien ils possèdent à la fois une énergie cinétique du fait de leur vitesse et une énergie potentielle d'interaction.
Ces deux énergies forment donc cette énergie interne qui contribue à 99% à la masse des protons et les neutrons.
Donc vous voyez que pour les protons et les neutrons, qui représentent quand même l'immense majorité de la matière qui nous entoure,
l'origine de la masse n'est pas la masse des constituants, les quarks, mais c'est leur énergie : leur énergie cinétique et leur énergie
d'interaction. En fait pour être exact la situation est un peu plus complexe. On l'a dit, quand on essaye d'éloigner deux quarks
la force entre les deux augmente et du coup ça a une conséquence un peu contre-intuitive,
c'est qu'il n'est pas possible d'observer un quark isolé, tout seul : c'est ce qu'on appelle le confinement des quarks.
Et si on essaye quand même de tirer sur cette sorte de ressort au bout d'un moment il se passe un truc étonnant.
Le ressort, c'est-à-dire le gluon en fait, se désintègre et l'énergie qu'il contenait se transforme en une paire d'un quark et d'un anti-quark,
qui d'ailleurs peuvent être d'un type différent de up & down,
et inversement une paire quark anti-quark peut fusionner et
disparaître en redonnant de l'énergie au gluon. Et en fait ce rythme de création et
disparition de paires de quarks se produit à un rythme effréné à l'intérieur des protons et des neutrons.
Et donc une image correcte de leur structure interne
c'est pas tellement celle de trois quarks qui seraient gentiment reliés par les gluons mais plutôt d'une soupe de quarks, d'anti-quarks et de gluons qui
évoluent sans cesse
avec comme particularité qu'il y a au final toujours trois quarks de plus que les anti-quarks,
2 up 1 down pour un proton et 1 up 2 down pour un neutron.
Et de ce point de vue là, une manière un peu plus correcte de voir ces
99% d'énergie interne c'est en fait de les voir comme l'énergie de cette soupe.
Alors à ce stade de notre descente vous remarquerez qu'on a déjà expliqué 99% de la masse de la matière qui nous entoure
juste avec de l'énergie interne, l'énergie d'interaction des quarks, et on n'a toujours pas parlé de boson de Higgs...
Depuis le début on a dit que la nature de la masse c'était d'être de l'énergie, de l'énergie interne,
et ça a d'ailleurs bien fonctionné notamment parce qu'on a regardé des systèmes qui étaient composite, faits de plusieurs
constituants : un atome, un noyau, un proton... Mais un quark jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est une particule élémentaire,
composée de rien, alors même si sa masse ne compte que pour 1%
comment on l'explique, celle-là ? Eh bien c'est là qu'intervient le boson de Higgs ou plutôt le champ de Higgs.
Ah oui on parle toujours du boson, qui est la particule qu'on a détectée au Cern.
Vous savez peut-être qu'en mécanique quantique il y a le phénomène de dualité onde-corpuscule,
par exemple la lumière se comporte à la fois comme une particule, le photon, et comme une onde, le champ électromagnétique.
Eh bien pour le Higgs c'est pareil, et en fait le truc fondamental dans notre affaire c'est le champ de Higgs.
Le champ de Higgs c'est quelque chose qui baigne tout l'espace et qui a une petite particularité par rapport aux champs électromagnétiques.
Le champ électromagnétique son état de base c'est d'être à zéro.
S'il n'y a pas de source de radiations il n'y a pas d'onde et les champs électriques et magnétiques sont nuls.
Le champ de Higgs a comme particularité que son état de base, qu'on appelle son état fondamental, n'est pas nul
il est en quelque sorte toujours actif
et quand une particule, par exemple un quark, se trouve dans ce champ de Higgs
eh bien elle interagit avec lui et elle acquiert une certaine énergie du fait de cette interaction
un peu de la même façon qu'une particule chargée acquiert de l'énergie potentielle
électrostatique si on la met dans un champ électrique.
Mais si du fait de cette interaction le quark acquiert de l'énergie eh bien il acquiert aussi de la masse.
Et le mécanisme se généralise à toutes les particules élémentaires massives : elles acquièrent leur masse du fait de leur interaction avec le champ de Higgs
et parce que m = E sur c²
ou E = mc² si vous préférez...
Voilà vous savez tout sur la nature de la masse et comment E = mc² et le boson de Higgs conspirent dans cette affaire
pour nous rendre massifs. Si la vidéo vous a éclairés n'hésitez pas à la partager, à la liker et à vous abonner !
Je vous recommande d'ailleurs si vous ne l'avez pas déjà vue d'aller voir la vidéo sur la relativité restreinte.
Les actus de la chaîne c'est sur Facebook et Twitter, pour ceux qui veulent me soutenir ça se passe sur Tipeee, et vous pouvez aussi aller
jeter un œil à mon livre qui s'appelle Insoluble mais vrai, merci, à bientôt !